since there's been a huge rise in doing
aesthetic procedures in the last 19
years
everything is increased the good the bad
the ugly everything from common to
what's your approach a management
expectation because I'm very
straightforward I'm very dear and you
computer morphing I say here's what you
maybe could expect but it's not a
guarantee here are the negative things
that can happen I focus on the negatives
first so one of the things I like to do
is I like to bring entrepreneurs to you
from all different space not just one
specific industry and today we're going
to hold it from direction today we're
sitting with dr. paul nassif who is
somebody you've probably seen on TV if
you watch a show botched i think you
guys just renewed your fifth season
weekend it's airing right now it's
airing right now as we speak so here's a
facial plastic surgeon very well-known
in Beverly Hills if you say the name
here obviously a lot of people know him
being half Armenian half Assyrian hmm I
know our community contributes towards a
lot of the business that you do because
our nose is just such a perfect notes
bill for someone like you with the
business that you do plus I'm a Lebanese
boy so I know all about that yes a lot
of Middle Eastern patients a lot of
Armenians not many Assyrians them the
Armenians in the Middle East like us you
know we all got the noses and the
Iranians especially being in Beverly
Hills yeah that's exactly right
sometimes I wonder you know food cost
fifteen thousand dollars to make the
nose look good how much will it cost to
make somebody's nose look like mine
that's the real question
right Africa now although all the money
in the world it's gonna take a lot of
money for that what makes somebody wake
up in the morning say you know what
here's what I want to do when I grow up
I want to go be a facial plastic surgeon
what was you know you're not born with
that one you're born with being a doctor
though age of 12 is when I started
talking about becoming a doctor and then
when I was in medical school I got
excited about ear nose and throat
surgery because it was very cool the
anatomy was very different you know
you're dealing with the skull you're
dealing with the neck with all the vital
organs you're dealing with you know
cosmetic surgery and it excited me then
after you do that then I steered gives
an EMT you can go five different
directions to facial plastic surgery
because is the most intriguing and doing
a rhinoplasty which is about seven
five percent of my practice now a lot of
that is revision rhinoplasty fixing up
bad you know nose jobs revision is
second chime or on or no so 75 percent
my practice is revision kind of 25
percent first term then out of all the
noses out of that 75 percent probably 75
80 percent of that is revision surgery
so I got into liking facial plastic
surgery did a fellowship in that king of
Beverly Hills since I'm from LA opened
up in 1999 and I started doing replaster
a revision nasal surgery with not that
much experience and now it's kind of
what I do but at 12 years old so 12
years old you know you were gonna be a
dad parents doctors mom or dad uncle
uncle doc family practitioner we're good
old Glendale
we're actually near Glendale in Burbank
border so your uncle's a doctor yeah
he's gone now he was a dancer yes so
would you sit there and watch him and
say I want to be like uncle when I grow
up it was in a moment did you have a
special moment that no I just some I
liked it I just had many new I wanted to
do maybe was my mom saying my son the
doctor not my son the doctor might watch
you should have a Bostonian accent she
did oh she didn't she had the Bostonian
are you from you you so a your Bostonian
or what my mom said by the blood doesn't
bother you at all blood doesn't do a
half right otherwise I couldn't do it so
from the beginning like you when you
cutting none of that stuff does anything
for you yeah so when I was in the army
myself
oh these big guys athlete and they say
okay one of the things you need to do in
boot camp is you need to put an IV and
true friends are so everybody's looking
at each other thing you want me to put
an IV my friends are yes soldiers was it
would someone have to gotta take care oh
do you know how many people passed out
oh yeah guys pass it on biggest guys
with that's not the toughest guys in a
room or personnel because they're
tensing up and all said it's called
vagal they all pass
so you knew right off to bed this was
the route you were gonna go so let me
ask you how much has it changed from the
moment you went in in 99 to today 2018 I
mean from what I do
obviously the prices are went up
dramatically yes what was it in 90 now
what is it today give or take well plus
I'm a little bit on the higher end of
the spectrum so I do charge more because
I'm a specialist to what I do and it's
really hard but in general is probably
one up about three hundred percent three
hundred percent
99 till today in the surgeon phase
that's how I'm gonna sir maybe 250 to
the people's style or what they want it
keeps changing fluctuation of plastic
surgery of what it should look like and
our biggest thing now is natural
the other thing has changes we're trying
to do more non-invasive procedures and
good skin care products to make you not
aged as much rather than needing surgery
or very heavy-duty lasers mm-hmm so
we're doing more non-invasive stuff a
lot more doctors call cosmetic surgeons
which really aren't plastic surgeons
that are doing aesthetic work a lot more
medical spas like we have one but not in
a medical office things like that I mean
overall the plateau and also more of an
acceptance of having plastic surgery
it's grown especially the men to really
you think how much of that has been
because of social media and filters and
all this other stuff
everything research social media has
driven almost everything especially you
do your selfies in the filters and you
want to try to look like that also
people are hot they're getting botched a
lot of bad Plastic Surgeons or just bad
things happening to people but overall
is anything becomes more popular you
have more increase in everything
complications bad results great results
people dying from plastic surgery people
dying from leather surgery I mean all
kinds of things can happen so just in
general since there's been a huge rise
in doing aesthetic procedures in the
last 19 years
everything is increased the good the bad
the ugly everything so when you start
off day one you obviously came in being
a surgeon but you didn't have any
business background by do I do I have a
real estate finance degree from USC had
you ran a business before you were
sophomores in the restaurant business
for you so you were even before you I
knew I need about business which is rare
in doctors there we did have a
restaurant started waiting tables when I
was 16 I managed a top restaurant Sunset
Strip in West Hollywood during college
got a college I opened a restaurant with
my family but I ran it I ran in Pasadena
California great city what was it called
Holly Street Bar and Grill okay so
business background then you got into it
so that gives you an edge to be able to
also not only specialize but also scale
the business now how about the marketing
side like at what point did you say you
know what I kind of
what I'm doing but how about if we
decide to take this thing on TV and
having a reality show did they approach
you or did you say I'm willing to get a
little bit more public with what I'm
doing here today I mean every doctor
we're trying to pitch maybe having a TV
show that's a plastic surgery I've
always been on TV I always liked this
idea I was doing makeover shows back in
the early 2000s is that the doctor or
nine oh two one oh then I did that after
a little bit okay and then unfortunately
went on the duck Beverly Hills Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills how was that
it was tough but with that the / dude
that gave me the option for this because
the producers of that became my friends
and after that was over for us and a
divorce I was sat down with the
producers and I said you know let's do a
TV show where they we take messed up
plastic surgery and try to fix them on
TV and show all the complications and
show the healing issues so it's really
like and I called the buddy who's on the
show with me Terry Dubrow when I say
let's do this Snickers what are you
crazy we're gonna actually put
reputations out there and do I go yeah
let's do it
and so we made a little sizzle reel just
us talking about it and he picked it up
just like that
no no pilot straight to series eight
which is the first pickup usually and we
did it we filmed it and it was a viral
phenomenon and everyone liked it because
it has all the facets of you know
bromance comedy yes the crazy stories
cautionary tale and then the aspect of
helping other people the human interest
so all those are tied in and that's what
makes for a good TV and now we're in
season five and I hope our memories keep
going and you keep talking when I was
South America Central America they watch
you everywhere now everyone has 155
different countries that's nice and then
with that I developed a skincare line
which I love I've been into skincare for
ten years but I finally launched it on
Home Shopping Network two years ago I'm
going there next week and I go to
Australia we're now working on Amazon
and more ecommerce so I bought
anti-aging skin care line so you know
this whole skin thing you hear a lot of
people come up with skin products but I
was reading the reviews I read it where
somebody was saying you know you know
the skin product is good when I brought
it home and I was using it I couldn't
believe how amazing it was then I
noticed my daughter keeps taking it away
from me and she kept saying this thing
is amazing that I have to eventually go
back and buy it and there's not a lot of
skin products that I'm dead
but I am with Paul Nassif's products oh
yeah this is a real of your product so
what did you do
hey you said I'm gonna take a different
approach but our skin product and
everybody else first of all it's a lot
of good skincare products out there I'm
I sat down with a great formulator Matt
in New Jersey my friend of mine had the
company and we sat we talked for weeks
and weeks and weeks about different
products and different ideas so my whole
idea was to put a few different
ingredients as the main basis except we
would have other actives and different
products because want to make products
that are specific to certain areas of
your face like I have a forehead product
a periorbital around the eye under eye
product I have a neck product you know
the full set have different products
that are specific to the different parts
of your face so there's different active
ingredients depending on the thickness
of your skin you know your skin reacts
like the eyelid skin is the thinnest
skin in your body
so I wanted hydration as one main
feature and almost every product that I
have not moisturizing but hydration
getting actually you know the right
essence of fluids into the skin so
that's hyaluronic acid is one of the
main ways then there's other actor
products that help pull things in and
then I like retinol and vitamin C as my
two main carriers vitamin C is a great
antioxidant a retinol is a natural form
of vitamin A and it's stable not too
irritating but the combined together or
mixtures of both or single you can help
you know the blemishes the
discolorations help tighten help get rid
of the wrinkles so I focused on all
these and with hydration helps gets rid
of wrinkles too hydrating your skin so I
focused on these three main key points
and then added other active ingredients
and that's how I put this together and
what and the three worked very well
together where can we find it Nassif MD
skincare calm Nassif MD skincare doc
Omar let's put that link below yeah or
you could come to our office our
Nassif's skin care I mean a Nassif
medical spa or you can go to Home
Shopping Network and buy it there you're
gonna be there next week I'm gonna be
there next week do you know who Maxwell
Maltz is he wrote a book called psycho
cybernetics I think ended up somewhere
like 30 million books you probably were
thinking robbery or you know some of
these books business books that are out
there that well-known people of read
it's one of those books but he's an
original guy he's an old
cool guy he wasn't a facial he did
cosmetic surgery I think you would
really like this book he talks about in
the book that the more and more I did
and the more and more I wanted to help
these guys to go through their features
the more I realized not only did I have
to work on it on the outside but I also
have to work on people on the inside for
confidence at what point did you feel
like where did you ever have this
experience where you're not only a
facial cosmetic surgeon or you also feel
like you're a psychologist a little bit
to help with that side well if you watch
if you seen in the episodes on our show
where a psychologist all the time with
plastic surgery
your second calling is a psychologist we
have to evaluate patients for all kinds
of psychological illnesses personality
disorders or to find out are they they
have OCD are they have body dysmorphic
disorder
do they have narcissism or the associate
path are they plastic surgery attics are
the antibody modification what is the
natus for having plastic surgery is it
because they just got divorced we want
to feel better or because their
boyfriend or girlfriend is saying you
should do this matha know everything
you're really testing on oh that's a
good question no no I know I I can pull
it out okay don't ask those questions in
line but as I'm sitting talking to the
patient after doing this for a long time
I can see where the pathology is dry so
we have to make sure that everyone is
doing it for the right reason and not
unrealistic besides having a clear
psychological frame of mind has to be
perfect has to be crystal clear so how
often do you say no tool 10% really well
for what I do remember I do I see people
from all the world 50% my patients from
out of California out of those 20 to 25%
is from out of this country so I see
patients with very bad messed up
rhinoplasty and there's a lot of
pathology there there's a lot of
problems but you know a self confidence
I mean things that you feel really bad
depression everything and then on budge
for example because it's publicly you
can see it you take these people with
horrible horrible complications and that
their inner soul has been crushed and we
have the opportunity for example to give
that bad
so when we do something good it really
helps people that ever as long as
they're doing it for the right reason
right it's a right situation you and I
both know I lived here for 25 years I
live in Dallas now
and by the way Dallas has a pretty vein
city as well it's not like Dallas they
don't
a lot of everybody in Dallas wants to
look very very good it's a very very
competitive
Highland Park type of an environment and
there's nothing worse than bad plastic
surgery oh yeah you don't want any I
mean if you you can tell someone's that
plastic surgery it's not good so you
look at it when you see you know when
it's some bad work done or something
everyone knows I read somewhere that you
said so do you look at people and you
say hey you know you should get a nose
job I can help you really good I can
really help you make look you know make
it look better etc etc and I like what
you said you said no it's actually not
my approach I tell people you look
perfect but I can help so your
approaches more people are coming to you
so you're not going to people pitching
them on what they want to do they
typically come to you a young plastic
surgeon may do that in the beginning of
their but a senior you know seasoned
doctor would never do that
you don't walk up I mean that's the most
insulting thing in the world you know
you need you have your nose done you
need to have your ears pinned back
you need some Botox never patients come
up to me you know won't you ever wound
out a lot though you know you know
that's not appropriate right I'm with
you it's not professional yeah I mean
you're seeing him in a controversy right
now where some of those surgeons got
caught targeting ads on young teenage
girls and you know younger girls to go
out there and do this we're retargeting
stuff from their social media to it and
you're seeing it go a little bit that
direction do you see some of this stuff
making some of the younger girls and
even guys feel a little insecure the
fact that they're trying to keep up and
compete with it or is there a part of it
that you're saying well you know it's a
healthy aspect of all of us wanting to
look better combination okay so if it's
healthy some of it is insecurity if some
of it is keeping up with the Joneses I
mean especially the younger you know in
the Kardashian effect of big butts and
big lips I mean that's an international
rush because of that there is pressure
peer pressure sometimes to Billiken
that's why we have to evaluate what's
going on very important for us to figure
that out with each patient to make sure
they are the right candidate for surgery
because if you operate on the wrong
candidate it's not good all the way
around because one let's say I do a good
job on something but if it's the wrong
candidate besides driving me crazy the
patient whether it's the swelling in the
nose or whatever it is right and again
there's different aspects you can have a
patient not happening so we have to try
to figure out what is the main Ninus of
one early surgery I'm a business guy and
I got a big hump of my nose and it's
been driving me crazy for twenty years
you know what I'm gonna feel
if I get rid of out Clyde yeah let's do
it versus someone who comes in with six
pages of letters a description of what
they want every angle with a nose they
call micrographia when they write really
small and they're deciding exactly what
that technical with the angle this and
that they're then we're looking to I
mean there's all kinds of things Wow and
this is gonna help change a life and
they'll get them a job when you get them
out so yeah how do you manage it if I'm
if I'm come at you what is your approach
a manage and expectation with a custom
I'm very straightforward I'm very blunt
how'd you compute a more thing I say
here's what you maybe could expect but
it's not a guarantee and here are the
negative things that could happen I
focus on the negatives first see my
scale if they're cool with the negatives
then I co okay you passed that litmus
test let's now talk about hopefully what
we're gonna achieve with the nose
doesn't heal normally it heals in a
three-dimensional manner so in other
words I can do the same thing on both
sides the nose but once I could heal
different than overdoing your nose under
doing those Kazi nasal obstruction it's
more of collapse over time the more
aggressive you do the nose the more
risks are but again I do the face and
you can injure the facial nerve the
nerve that controls movements of your
face bleeding infection poor results
confirmation everything could happen
it's something that every time you
operate like tomorrow morning I'm doing
three surgeries in a row and tomorrow's
all noses usually their mixes of
everything and there's risks how many
total noses have you worked on it 10,000
hours it's a lot of noses to work on
right 10,000 and how technical is a
procedure brother was that a very
hardest hardest plastic surgical
procedure involved why is that nose
probably the healing issue okay and you
know you can just go there and whack
things away but then when you do that
that's when things get screwed up but
it's highly technical too just trying to
figure out how to make your nose look
good very hard to do when you're talking
about management expectation I was
working on Morgan standing with our
broker told us this it says listen
you're gonna have some clients are gonna
need to fire because you can have
clients that if the market does well
they're gonna call you a hundred times a
day if the market does bad and they're
gonna call you hundred times a day you
don't want those calls he says you need
to manage the expectation right up front
so they're not calling you 24/7 what did
it mark you have a good or bad sounds
like you're doing the same thing as well
oh we have to I tell them up front too I
go you can't call every minute they go
this is the process of healing
that's way it is so somebody in your
world if someone's getting started right
now what is one
way for somebody to differentiate
themselves in the industry you're part
of I wouldn't be too fun honest to me a
good doctor I think if you're a good
doctor and a good person and you go set
up your shingle you're gonna slowly grow
if you can actually get a niche market
of something that you do like I'm a
facial plastic surgeon I do everything
but now I've become known as the nose
specialist so I've kind of pigeon-holed
myself in that but it's the hardest
surgery of all but I like doing it but I
also like doing facelifts so if you do
that if you pick something that you
really specialize in a different part of
the body and you know it very very well
as a super specialist that's fantastic
so you do the face lift as well on top
of yeah is the 40s question you said
right do you know the whole face so
what's the secret sauce to the facelifts
so the Joker smile doesn't come out you
know sometimes you hear about the dogs
when you pull this way yeah the best way
to do is everything is lifted up in a
vertical manner got it that way we do it
that way it's just a preference
preference or maybe that's for style
Bester style you see the small when they
do it it completely changes the lives on
some who take that rod as somebody who
has looked at many different woman in
his life you can tell a big difference
when something is done a little bit too
much versus something that's done too
little I was in Colorado skiing and this
lady I sit down next to my wife and I
and I said so what he did for them is
I'm a dentist I'm like let me ask you a
question when you look at everybody
would you first look at do you look at
their teeth is I always look at their
teeth I said what do you look for she
said I look to see the color I said
interesting being the fact that you do
what you do do you look at everybody's
can you help yourself I'm looking at
their noses but if you always kind of
look at it you know what well if I had
like an hour and a half beer I can
really help them a little bit a glance
looking for pretty noses so being the
world that you're in give us a pretty
nose who has a really pretty nose that
you'd say that to me is a very nice note
you know men and well a beautiful female
still Megan Fox still has a gorgeous
knows where all of all the actress Grace
Kelly you know a guy I've had my nose
done four times how do you yourself like
you sit down nobody mine but I had skin
cancer over here
I personally you know now I mean when I
look at a good-looking nose I gotta tell
you I know it sounds weird but my nose
is a good-looking nails now I mean the
profile is sharp it's nice and it's
strong I'm not a movie star but I think
that a lot of my patients
my nose and want me to try to get
something like that what's crazy about
your nose is it doesn't look like you
don't work on it yeah because except me
to learn and like I said I have scars
here I have all the types of things but
I have a lot of reconstruction here but
it looks good it looks natural yeah I'm
gonna say my nose you're gonna say your
no I'm gonna say my nose props to you
man you know not a lot of people can
tell themselves they're the best but
you're saying I Sam I have a good
looking nose now but it took four years
or whatever it was to get your work who
do you trust
I flew her buddy of mine out in Chicago
he there's a from he comes in from
Chicago you know I flew out to go see
you buddy you flew out to Chicago and
all the four have been done by your
friend no you did last one he did the
last one for him kinda like you to trust
somebody that's a lot of credibility to
have a friend do this look no one gets
to your level in any space on what they
do without having certain disciplines
Paul behind this behind all these things
that you've built and behind everything
that you're doing in the position you
have in town where everybody in Beverly
goes if they mentioned and then your
name is gonna come up what are some
daily disciplines you've had over the
years that's helped you that may be at
some point when you also became a
surgeon like some of the other peers
they didn't have certain disciplines
that helped you get to a level that
Europe right now I'm gonna say that this
has kind of become you know more in line
for me recently but one thing I gotta
tell you is you got to keep focused all
the time
sleeping I'm good at least seven hours
working out in the morning before work
before they're beginning the day these
are my discipline you start in the
morning 5:30 or 6:00 no matter what I'm
working about five days a week so you
should be burning I mean now I used to
not sleep as much but now I really try
to go to bed and get a good seven hours
sometimes even these are disciplines
that I feel you're setting yourself up
for success
I've lost a good amount of weight
because that's actually not good for
your health
I do intermittent fasting I don't eat
for 16 hours a day our CFO does that as
well
and I try to now cut down the flour and
the sugar so discipline food have you
always been like this or this is reason
to discipline I haven't always working
out yes but now I'm more disciplined
especially as I'm getting older I got to
be able to go and they long got it
plus I have other things I have a
medical practice have a show I'm a
skincare line I got a medical spa which
does everything I have children
girlfriend you got to be able to juggle
all this final thoughts I'll give it to
you we're in a very competitive
environment as entrepreneurs if you
don't get better I mean the world of
capitalism somebody wants your
marketplace that's you wake up every
single day somebody wants your name
someone shows somebody wants watch
somebody wants your territory somebody
wants your customers you know what I
want to take you out yes how do you
consistently stay competitive and by the
way two ways I want this to be answered
if you don't mind taking a diss
direction one not the 2018 massive dr.
Nassif I wanted 1999-2000 when you were
coming up dr. Nassif as well as today
back then for me the thing was since it
was already a thousand fish there was a
small fish in a big pond in Beverly
Hills
stoechas there's still a thousand
doctors so with that how do you take a
small fish in a big pond and make them a
whale and back then I said to myself one
I have to keep learning keep my mind
open to learning about new procedures
how to constantly improve and as I
mentioned I had a pick an area where
there was a weakness in the market and
it was revision rhinoplasty or nose jobs
so that's that those are my two concepts
that I debated now one thing I still
hold to this many years later is no
matter how good I am I'm constantly
learning and constantly upgrading and
changing and devising and writing
research papers changing the way I do
different parts of the nose every year
or so different parts keep changing how
do you get better with that there you go
other places to see you may go other
places or you in the middle of surgery
and you say you don't I'm gonna try this
and you think and you experiment not an
experiment you're gonna cause a bad
problem right but you have to you mine
us to keep growing and thinking you have
to take constructive criticism you have
to look at your results critically who
gives you construct constructive
criticism got it at my level no one's
gonna give it to me I have to do to
myself I focus on my nose is my
post-operative and I look at areas where
I'm not happy with so I kept that I kept
that I have to be self disciplined to
keep making sure that I strive to be
better take constructive criticism for
myself learn new techniques from
everybody whether they're just brand new
or 50 years in practice and I think if
you can keep an open mind
not be a narcissist I think that you're
not the best one in the world and you'll
never learn say you know what I'm good
at what I do but I can still learn a
hell of a lot more that's gonna keep you
on top of your game
are you a big reader medically I have to
read a lot plus with my business the
issue is I have all my emails to do with
late at night so I don't have a lot of
free time except for the weekends then
one on the weekends if I'm not with the
kids I love to read what do you read I
just
I've been reading recently political
books such as I just read the James
Comey book which is the higher loyal
loyalty I liked it I did vote for Trump
I liked the book you know it shed some
different light
but then I've been I haven't all I know
is I've been walking by my rooms and
seeing that there's some kind of issue
going on right now with an FBI probe or
something going on so when I saw commis
name up there someone said okay now
what's happening so it was an
interesting book just about the world of
Justice the White House and about FBI
than also read even though I kept an
open mind but I read that Fist of Fury
or fist yes which I read about that
it was entertaining no it was because a
lot of the characters in that book
you'll learn about personalities it's a
learning process to read now whether all
that you have to be given with a grain
of salt but now I'm gonna read and I'll
meet another political book coming up
you know I'm gonna read now something on
the pro side in any game you know is
that though is that it no well that's
skinny I've not read skin in the game
you know you gotta recap but I'll be my
next one I'll go by now so I'm reading
about all these different things
interesting and so I'm so now what I'm
reading about more than anything I've
highly gotten into politics in the last
two three four months what caused it I
don't know I just started getting into
it you know we don't know what's gonna
happen good bad indifferent we don't
know how strange is that on that the
politics is coming so in the last I've
sat down with Jerry Springer he went
straight politics there's a heated
debate we had a great time together
Ben Shapiro politics Arianna Huffington
politics the Praeger happy I don't know
if you know Prager Dennis Prager local
big big radio gone Carol a laugher
Arthur are you familiar well Arthur
Laffer the the Laffer curve the guy who
was yes yes economist for you know Kemp
and Bush and Reagan and all these guys
yeah I think you'll enjoy skin it again
if you're looking for really good I
don't think you're gonna be able to put
I get a lot of book recommendation cyber
at 15 1600 books very easier to keep me
and skin in a game I just couldn't I'm
reading every one of his books he's got
four books out I'm reading all four of
them
I finished skin and again last week I
got three more to go now I'm reading
another strategy book right now that's
just 700 page strategy book that
explains every single strategy that's
been used in every aspect of life
religion Democratic Party the devil
politics controlling military generals
Napoleon Prince Machiavelli
and it's like 600 pages of every single
historical strategy that was ever used
against people it's in there in one book
so instead of reading all these books
it's all in it fascinating I never
recommend six 700 page books but it's an
incredible book that's the next I'll
send it to you can we make an Oda to
listen both of them I want you to keep a
couple things in mind
you know sometimes inspiration on what
somebody wants to do in their lives
happens like this it is so weird on how
it happened people asked me to say Pat
did you think you were gonna go into
financial services and be a stockbroker
at Morgan Stanley Dean Witter no it's
called I watched Gordon Gekko and
bethbabs and I said like what I'm giving
it seven and getting into the industry
somebody may be watching this right now
you may listen to the story I like his
style and his swagger that he has and
you may say look I may want to get into
the space in a complete different
country and he's in Beverly Hills cuz by
the way in here one out of ten people
you run into it's pretty pretty much a
plastic surgeon so to make it to his
level this is not an easy place to make
it to his level in Beverly Hills when I
said one out of ten I'm making up that
number that's not a factual set I'm just
making a point to that there's a lot of
people here that do what he does but if
you got any questions you're big you're
big on Twitter on Instagram I see you're
pretty active on Twitter every once in a
while maybe more on Instagram Twitter I
mean I again I have a little help with
that stuff because I don't person is
that gonna do you or is there gonna be I
have my nephew's help me with my social
me so what can they get ahold of you
that maybe they're gonna hear back from
you if they message you the best way
probably to do it is to go to dr. dr
paul nassif comm and then there's
increase and you can actually and they
do come to the office and they're given
to me versus call my office I'm in
Beverly Hills call his office man he's
in Beverly Hills okay you're talking to
the man
dr. paul nassif brother thank you so
much for taking a touch really enjoyed
it take you everybody